i
And my mouth and my little friend is more than
To avoid it is like another
daughter
the first time I went on stage and I
At the beginning of the show I was a little
shy right?
but the public reaction was wonderful
and from here to there has always been
Wonderful world
it is very important to keep in mind that the
Islam and music
they have nothing in common like any other
other type of faith or doctrine do not
nothing in common they only find in me
because by chance, by mere chance, I
I am Muslim then Islam is the religion
I'm a professional musician and the music
at work
because I really have not had much
problem in relation to the family in
friends around me and I really do not
I had a lot of trouble, it was something like that.
very natural
My mother is when she first saw me.
time I was wearing this outfit that
I use she looked at me from top to bottom
and she said you look very pretty
criticism always at criteria is healthy
because I believe that all unanimity
It's an expression of stupidity, I do not
I intend to please everyone
I only intend to do mine.
music and official funks for all